Luna bailed économiste Joseph Stiglitz
arash sujatmi Larry Anthony Atkinson PO
légalité
Alucard roots festival littéraire
international métropole blue amore L
Supriya présente Apollo observer à notre
québécois Disney Garrity Joseph Stiglitz
huit économiste Township modèle de banque de données
cosy économie Président Clinton œuf
Alma publicité Osceola capitalisme solaire
un polaire  système les gens le pouvoir et les profits
nouveau niveau notre pays un burrito mr.
Stieglitz BOSU ravi d'être ici ravi de
vous accueillir à Montréal c'est un
honneur de vous rencontrer et de vous accueillir dans
cette émission aujourd'hui
vous venez de publier ce livre le
pouvoir des gens et les profits et vous parlez de
capitalisme progressiste qu'est-ce que
le capitalisme progressiste eh bien l'idée est
que  afin de s'assurer que l'
économie sert la société, nous devons avoir un
nouvel équilibre entre le marché, l'État
et la société civile le fait que j'utilise
le mot capitalisme signifie que le
marché va être une partie importante
mais la raison pour laquelle j'utilise le  le mot
progressiste est la façon dont le marché a
fonctionné dans le passé la façon dont il a
fonctionné au cours des 44 40 dernières années
aux États-Unis n'a pas servi la plupart
de nos citoyens pour certaines personnes
le capitalisme progressif c'est c'est une façon
de rendre le capitalisme acceptable pour les autres
les gens le capitalisme progressiste pourrait être
plus d'impôts et des impôts plus élevés ce n'est pas
seulement une question d'impôts l'un des points que
je fais valoir dans le livre est que la façon dont l'
économie de marché sur son  propre a
travaillé crée beaucoup d'inégalités les
règles du jeu en favorisent quelques-uns et c'est
pourquoi j'utilise le mot pouvoir
c'est le pouvoir du peuple et les profits c'est le pouvoir de
générer des profits contre l'intérêt
du peuple ouais
et nous avons l'exploitation l'exploitation du
pouvoir de marché l'exploitation  des travailleurs
exploitation des clients exploitation
de l'environnement
le point important que j'essaie de faire
est que ce type d'
exploitation ralentit en fait l'économie
ralentit la croissance économique afin que nous puissions
avoir une prospérité plus partagée plus de croissance
si nous avions un meilleur système de  un
système plus égalitaire et c'est avant que nous parlions
de taxes de redistribution, il s'agit vraiment
des fondamentaux de base du fonctionnement de l'
économie dans votre livre vous dites que
Donald Trump a un bon diagnostic de la
situation mais pas la bonne réponse à la
façon dont le capitalisme progressiste pourrait
assurez-vous que
les accords commerciaux du capitalisme de la mondialisation créent la confiance des gens
au lieu de la colère, de la frustration et de la
désinformation  rmation ouais alors quand je dis que
Trump a un bon diagnostic, laissez-moi dire à quoi
il a vraiment été sensible,
il y a beaucoup de malheur là-bas beaucoup
de gens ont été laissés pour compte beaucoup de
gens se sentent désespérés c'est l'une
des raisons pour lesquelles la vie  l'espérance
aux États-Unis diminue les décès
de désespoir les gens peuvent nommer le suicide une
surdose d'alcoolisme les symptômes d'un
trouble social, il l'a donc reconnu, mais
il leur a fait une fausse promesse qu'il
allait faire quelque chose à ce sujet et était
triste bien sûr ce qu'il a fait est  réduit les
impôts et les milliardaires de la
société ont augmenté l'impôt sur le
milieu et supprimé l'assurance maladie
pour des millions d'Américains que
vous savez tous qu'il essaie de faire qu'il a
en fait réussi à retirer
à certains qu'il ne l'a pas détruit en  une
manière qu'il a voulu mais mais il a
déjà réussi et affaibli le
système mais pensez-vous qu'il y a une
part parce que Donald Trump a promis de
ramener l'emploi  s pour protéger les emplois pour
créer des emplois, le taux de chômage est
supérieur à quatre pour cent en ce moment
y a-t-il une petite partie des politiques de Donald
Trump qui réduisent les inégalités à votre
avis, la plupart de ses politiques
augmentent en fait les inégalités son programme de
protectionnisme, il va en fait faire du
mal  les personnes mêmes qu'il dit qu'il
essaie d'aider, la raison en est
que nous sommes dans une économie mondialisée lorsque
nous avons mondialisé, cela leur a fait du mal, mais maintenant où
nous en sommes à D mondialiser sans protection sociale, cela
va leur faire encore du mal,
ils vont le faire  soit qu'ils vont être
moins compétitifs, la fabrication américaine
sera moins compétitive moi et même s'il
a réussi à ramener des emplois qui,
je ne crois pas, les emplois croient
des emplois différents de ceux que ces emplois
ont perdus, la fabrication qui
va venir  le retour va être fait
principalement par des robots principalement par l'IA et il
va être situé à des endroits différents
des endroits où les emplois ont été perdus
où malheureusement nous  n'ont pas investi
dans la technologie de l'éducation de la manière
dont nous aurions dû vous faire publier de nombreux
livres au cours des dernières décennies la légalité le
prix d'une égalité c'était en 2012 vous avez
écrit à l'époque juste après Occupy
Wall Street qu'il y a un
sentiment croissant de  l'injustice et un sentiment de
trahison diriez-vous que l'élection
de Donald Trump est une conséquence directe
de ces sentiments et j'ai dit
dans ce livre qu'à moins que nous ne creusions
quelque chose au-dessus de l'inégalité, cela
ouvrirait la porte à un démagogue et il
avait  été plus tôt que prévu tu sais que tu en
parles je pense que c'est arrivé
plus tôt et je pense que c'était un démagogue
qui était pire que ce à quoi je m'attendais
ouais
que quelqu'un n'est même pas ancré
dans la vérité ne comprend pas vraiment les
fondements de ce qui fait pour  la richesse
des nations qui concerne l'
investissement dans l'innovation dans la recherche et les gens qu'il
essaie de réduire notre budget de recherche
essayer de réduire l'éducation universitaire
attaquer l'éducation attaquer  g vérité nous
ne pouvons pas avoir une société qui fonctionne
sans alors Ruth diriez-vous qu'il est
le résultat d'inégalités dans de nombreuses sectes
oui il l'est et le titre de mon livre le
prix de l'inégalité j'ai choisi très
soigneusement de dire aux lecteurs que vous connaissez en
résumant  un sens et une phrase
ce dont parlait le livre concernait l'
idée qu'à moins que nous ne fassions quelque chose contre l'
inégalité, nous paierions un
prix très élevé, ce serait un prix à gagner
dans notre économie, nous grandirions plus lentement,
mais j'ai également averti que c'était  un prix pour notre
démocratie ouais que nous serions la proie d'une
sorte de démagogue et j'ai dit que c'était aussi
un prix pour notre société car cela
conduirait à une société plus divisée et
malheureusement nous le voyons aussi
autour des États-Unis
Trump est  parce qu'il est moi alors je dis
mal parce qu'il est si mauvais qu'il est il a été
amené de l'autre côté et a dit
que ce n'est pas une Amérique en laquelle nous croyons,
nous devons restaurer la confiance dans notre
gouvernement, nous devons restaurer l'unité
parmi notre peuple  ici au Québec les
inégalités sont parmi les plus faibles en
Amérique du Nord le marché crée des
inégalités vous avez dit que beaucoup d'
économistes disent dire cela mais des études montrent
que le gouvernement réduit les inégalités
et nous avons des études et des kanuk disant
que montrer que c'est l'implication du
gouvernement est la  toute première réponse pour
réduire les inégalités pour vous c'est un
élément absolument essentiel pour
réduire les inégalités vous savez quel que soit
le système économique que vous avez, vous allez
avoir des inégalités et le
gouvernement a un rôle important à jouer pour
atténuer ou aux extrêmes des
inégalités pour s'assurer par exemple
qu'aucun enfant n'est laissé sans
éducation parce que ces parents ne peuvent pas
se le permettre, mais c'est aussi le cas que
le gouvernement doit établir les règles
du jeu afin qu'il n'y ait pas autant d'
inégalité dans les revenus du marché, c'est
là que je souligne le rôle important  de la politique de la
concurrence afin que vous n'ayez pas le
glamour du pouvoir de marché qui conduit
à l'inégalité est un revenu de marché y  ous
avez besoin de droits de succession pour ne pas avoir
une ploutocratie héritée que nous
développons actuellement aux états-unis l'un des
plus grands défis de notre époque c'est le
réchauffement climatique vous avez co-présidé la
commission sur la taxe carbone avec l'
économiste britannique Nicholas Stern est l'idée  de
Justin Trudeau ici au Canada pour mettre un
prix sur le carbone est une bonne chose à faire
oui c'est vous savez qu'un prix du carbone est
nécessaire pour encourager le genre d'
innovation le genre de passer à une
économie verte mais ce n'est pas suffisant vous
devez combiner  qu'avec l'
infrastructure publique avec d'autres changements, vous
savez les changements de zonage dans l'utilisation des terres, beaucoup d'
autres choses qui doivent aller de
pair et encore une fois, il faut être très prudent
dans le calendrier et le séquencement de ces
changements, mais la nécessité d'évoluer
vers une économie verte  Je ne peux pas
souligner à la fois l'urgence et l'ampleur
de ce qui est nécessaire et ensuite pourquoi j'ai encore une fois
une telle admiration que certains
jeunes aux États-Unis ont
parlé de th  La mobilisation verte du New Deal en temps de guerre
c'est quelque chose qui
n'est vraiment pas quelque chose que vous pouvez dire eh bien
nous nous en occuperons dans 15 ans
c'est quelque chose qui
doit être fait maintenant m.  Stieglitz c'était
un très grand autre de vous accueillir et de
vous avoir merci beaucoup ravi d'être
ici merci je t'aime merci